The first video we talked about
for diffusion and for concentration gradients,
we had a vessel containing only one kind of particle.
We had these purple particles.
In this case, the concentration of purple particles
was higher than the left side,
than on the right.
So, if we look at this concentration gradient,
he is going from
the higher concentration on the left
to the lower concentration on the right.
We saw what happened.
Because we have more particles here
and they bounce around
in different random directions,
there is a greater likelihood that particles will move
from left to right, from right to left.
We will have particle transfers and from right to left,
but there will be
greater likelihood of movement from left to right.
Besides, if we wait for a while, the particles
will be distributed evenly in court.
They have moved in the direction of their concentration gradient
and distributed evenly in court.
Interesting in the chart we see now is,
that I have added a second type of particles,
these large yellow particles.
We see the concentration gradient of these particles
is in the opposite direction.
We have low concentration,
we actually do not have any yellow particles on the left.
We do not have any yellow particles
to the left and
high concentration of yellow particles on the right.
Their concentration gradient is from right to left.
The purpose of this video is
to show that each particle moves in the direction
of its own concentration gradient.
Unless blocked in any way,
it will move in the direction of its unique concentration gradient,
no matter what they do
other particles. At least for most of the time.
So, we see that the yellow particles will move
from a high place to a low concentration.
They will move
by diffusion from right to left.
This is not magic.
This molecule has not said,
"Oh, here are seven more of my friends,
it's a little cluttered, I feel claustrophobic,
I will move on the other side. "
Not that happens.
The particles simply bounce randomly
and when in the beginning
we have a situation like this, there is no chance
yellow particles to move from left to right,
because there are no yellow particles here.
But it is likely after a certain time, some of them
these yellow particles do
move from right to left.
They will continue to do so,
until they reach a stable configuration,
where there is the same probability
to move the particles from left to right and right to left.
This will happen in both particle types.
In biology or chemistry classes
you will often hear about things that are moving in the direction of
our concentration gradient, we can add
in the direction of its unique concentration gradient.
As you saw, the concentration gradient of the yellow particles
is in the opposite direction to that of the purple particles.
This is not magic.
You just have to imagine the particles
bouncing around in different directions.
What is the natural thing that can happen?
There will be a greater likelihood that the particles will move from place to point
higher concentration to a lower concentration site,
from a place with a lower concentration to a place with a higher concentration.